If you want more from the show, join The Rest Is History Club. And with Christmas coming, you can also gift a whole year of access to the history lover in your life. Just head to the restishistory.com and click gifts. This episode is sponsored by Hive. Britain revolutionised the future with the might of industrial power. But now you can transform your own energy future and take control with the power of Hive. Hive makes the most of the sun, with solar panels turning sunlight into greener electricity and enabling you to sell excess back to the grid. And Hive's thermostats make it possible
如果您想了解更多节目内容，请加入“历史余韵俱乐部”（The Rest Is History Club）。随着圣诞节临近，您也可以为身边的历史爱好者送上一份全年会员资格作为礼物。只需访问therestishistory.com并点击“礼物”（gifts）即可。本期节目由Hive赞助。英国曾以强大的工业力量彻底改变了未来。但现在，您可以利用Hive的力量，掌控并改变您自己的能源未来。Hive充分利用太阳能，通过太阳能电池板将阳光转化为更环保的电力，并让您能将多余的电力卖回电网。此外，Hive的恒温器让您能够
for you to heat your home without lifting anything more than a thumb and an impressed brow. Their heat pumps draw warmth from the air and they keep it exactly where you want it. No smoke, no waste. Hive's EV charger. your car charge quietly overnight. Recharging while you do too. Hive brings it all together. Heating, charging and solar managed from one simple app in a quiet revolution. In the long history of power, Hive helps you finally know yours. Head to hivehome.com to find out more. Subject to survey and suitability. Hive app compatible with selected technology. Paid for surplus requires
只需动动手指、挑挑眉毛，就能轻松调节家中温度。他们的热泵从空气中汲取热量，并将其精准保持在您想要的温度。没有烟雾，没有浪费。Hive的电动汽车充电器能让您的爱车在夜间安静充电，在您休息的同时完成补能。Hive将这一切融为一体。供暖、充电和太阳能管理，只需一个简单的应用程序，即可实现一场安静的革命。在漫长的能源史上，Hive终于让您掌握了自己的能源。访问hivehome.com了解更多信息。需视勘测和适用性而定。Hive应用程序兼容特定技术。出售多余电力需要
SEG tariff. An old woman who was known by the subrichay of Mother Crackham rather startled me
SEG关税。一位被称为“克拉克汉姆妈妈”（Mother Crackham）的老妇人让我大吃一惊，
by rushing up as I stood at the fireplace and demanded you to know if I was Jack the Ripper. The awkwardness of answering this
因为当我站在壁炉旁时，她冲过来质问我是否就是“开膛手杰克”。对于回答这个问题所带来的尴尬，
question I was happily relieved of by the old dame herself assuring me that she did not think I was. I know you ain't him, she said. You wouldn't rip me up, would you know? By and by,
我感到非常庆幸，因为这位老太太自己向我保证，她并不认为是我。她说：“我知道你不是他，你不会把我开膛破肚的，对吧？”不久之后，
the proceedings in the kitchen became more lively. Girls commence singing songs and the poet of the company entertained the room with the chorus of his latest composition. Has anyone seen him? Can you tell us where he is? If you meet him, you must take away his knife. Then give him to the women, they'll spoil his pretty fizz, and I wouldn't give him to tuppence for his life. Now at night when you're undressed and about to go to rest, just see that he ain't underneath the bed. If he is, you mustn't shout,
厨房里的气氛变得更加活跃。姑娘们开始唱歌，公司里的诗人用他最新创作的合唱曲招待了大家。有人见过他吗？你能告诉我们他在哪吗？如果你遇见他，一定要夺走他的刀。然后把他交给女人们，她们会毁了他那张漂亮的脸蛋，我可不会为他的命花上两便士。现在，当你在晚上脱衣准备休息时，一定要看看他是不是躲在床底下。如果他在那儿，你千万别大喊大叫，
but politely drag him out. And with your poker, tap him on the head. So that, Dominic, was the evening news, published on the 5th of October 1888 by a top investigative journalist describing the atmosphere in Cooney's Lodging House on the notorious Flower and Dean Street which was
而是要礼貌地把他拖出来。然后用你的火钳，敲他的脑袋。所以，多米尼克，这就是1888年10月5日由一位顶级调查记者发表的晚间新闻，描述了臭名昭著的“花与迪恩街”（Flower and Dean Street）上库尼寄宿公寓（Cooney's Lodging House）里的氛围，那正是
the lodging house that had been used by Jack the Ripper's latest victim and we are of course in Spittal Fields in White Chapel in the east end
“开膛手杰克”最新受害者所住的寄宿公寓，我们当然是在伦敦东区的白教堂（White Chapel）斯皮塔佛德（Spittal Fields），
of London it's the autumn of 1888 and we are deep into the story of the most notorious murderer of all time Jack the Ripper
那是1888年的秋天，我们正深入探讨史上最臭名昭著的杀手——“开膛手杰克”的故事。
yes and the lodging house judging by that reading full of Australians was Australians was Cockneys That sounds like Russell Crowe to me Well, the Australian accent does derive from Cockney
是的，从那段阅读来看，寄宿公寓里全是澳大利亚人，全是伦敦土话（Cockney）。听起来像罗素·克劳。嗯，澳大利亚口音确实源自伦敦土话。
Of course it does Couldn't be more Cockney And it's a kind of It's a reminder of just how obsessed by this point Everybody is with the story of Jack the Ripper Not just in London, not just across Britain But across the whole world Yeah, absolutely
当然是这样。再没有比这更地道的伦敦土话了。这提醒了我们，此时此刻每个人对“开膛手杰克”的故事是多么着迷。不仅是在伦敦，不仅是在英国，而是在全世界。是的，绝对是这样。
And I guess the reason for that is that No one knows who he is And that of course remains the case to this day So why are people so fascinated, partly because the case seems to embody so many of the anxieties of late Victoria in London, but also the inherent fascination of the case. It's so savage and so horrific. But also that mystery, right? He's the thief in the night, the ghost in the shadows who's escaping. And that's, of course, why we're still so fascinated and why almost uniquely among serial killer stories, this one has an extraordinary hold on the world's imagination. Yeah, and I think also what we shouldn't overlook is the sheer terror that he is inspiring, because those songs, you know, you sing them to keep your spirits up, but they're expressive of an absolute dread. People are terrified. Of course, and with good reason. So we ended last time on a cliffhanger, so let's remind ourselves where we've got to. I mean, the reason people are terrified is that there have been a series of horrific crimes. The death, first of all, of Martha Tabram on the 7th of August, then Marianne or Polly Nichols on the third. 31st of August, her body literally ripped apart, ripped open. And then another body ripped open that of Annie Chapman on the 8th of September in a backyard at Hambrey Street, Spittlefields. And we entered last time on the night of Saturday, the 29th and Sunday the 30th of September, when the killer has struck again, not once but twice.
我想原因在于没人知道他是谁，而这一点至今仍然如此。那么为什么人们如此着迷呢？部分原因是这个案件似乎体现了维多利亚时代晚期伦敦的许多焦虑，但也因为案件本身固有的吸引力。它太残忍、太恐怖了。但还有那种神秘感，对吧？他是黑夜里的窃贼，是阴影中逃脱的幽灵。当然，这就是为什么我们仍然如此着迷，以及为什么在连环杀手的故事中，这个故事几乎独一无二地对世界想象力有着非凡的掌控力。是的，我认为我们也不应忽视他所激发的纯粹恐惧，因为那些歌，你知道，你唱它们是为了振奋精神，但它们表达的是一种绝对的恐惧。人们吓坏了。当然，而且理由充分。所以我们上次在悬念中结束，让我们回顾一下我们讲到了哪里。我的意思是，人们感到恐惧的原因是发生了一系列可怕的罪行。首先是8月7日玛莎·塔布拉姆（Martha Tabram）的死亡，然后是8月31日的玛丽安或波莉·尼科尔斯（Polly Nichols），她的尸体被彻底撕裂、剖开。接着是9月8日在斯皮塔佛德汉布里街（Hambrey Street）后院，安妮·查普曼（Annie Chapman）的尸体也被剖开。我们上次是在9月29日星期六到9月30日星期日那个晚上结束的，当时杀手再次作案，而且是一晚两次。
So first of all, we had the discovery of the body of Elizabeth Stride, just inside Dutfield's Yard, which is just outside a socialist club for Russian and Polish Jewish immigrants. And then 45 minutes later, as we described last time, P.C. Edward Watkins is patrolling Mitre Square just off Allgate. So that's just inside the boundary of the city of London. So to the west of the other crimes. And he flashes his lantern. He finds something huddled on the ground. And then he's rushing across the square where we ended last time to a watchman.
首先，我们在达特菲尔德庭院（Dutfield's Yard）内发现了伊丽莎白·斯泰德（Elizabeth Stride）的尸体，那里就在一家俄罗斯和波兰犹太移民社会主义俱乐部外面。45分钟后，正如我们上次所描述的，警员爱德华·沃特金斯（P.C. Edward Watkins）正在奥尔盖特（Allgate）附近的米特广场（Mitre Square）巡逻。所以那是在伦敦市的边界内。也就是在其他犯罪地点的西边。他闪动灯笼，发现地上蜷缩着什么东西。然后他冲过广场，也就是我们上次结束的地方，去找一名更夫。
For God's sake, mate, come to my assistance. There's another woman cut to pieces. So let's pick up the story. So within about a quarter of an hour, a group of policemen had gathered around the body. And they're joined at about 220 by the city police surgeon, Dr. Frederick Gordon Brown. And it's from him that we get the, again, gruesome details of the crime scene. So to reiterate, if you are driving along with very small children in the back, listening to a podcast about the Jack the Ripper, you will be unsurprised to hear that there are some gruesome details to come.
“看在上帝的份上，伙计，快来帮我。又有一个女人被切碎了。”让我们继续讲这个故事。大约一刻钟内，一群警察聚集在尸体周围。大约凌晨2点20分，城市警察外科医生弗雷德里克·戈登·布朗（Dr. Frederick Gordon Brown）医生也加入了他们。正是从他那里，我们得到了犯罪现场令人毛骨悚然的细节。所以重申一下，如果您正带着很小的孩子在车里听关于“开膛手杰克”的播客，听到接下来会有一些恐怖细节，请不要感到惊讶。
So rethink your choices. The victim says Dr. Frederick Gordon Brown is lying on her back with her throat cut, her body horribly mutilated. To quote him, the abdomen was all exposed. the intestines were drawn out to a large extent and placed over the right shoulder. A piece of about two feet was quite detached from the body and placed between the body and the left arm, apparently by design. So this is a really unsettling, you know, unbelievably unsettling and strange scene, almost kind of ritualistic.
所以请重新考虑一下。弗雷德里克·戈登·布朗医生说，受害者仰面躺着，喉咙被割开，尸体被严重损毁。引用他的话：“腹部完全暴露，肠子被大量拉出，放在右肩上。一段约两英尺长的肠子完全与身体分离，放在身体和左臂之间，显然是刻意为之。”所以这是一个非常令人不安、难以置信地令人不安且奇怪的场景，几乎带有一种仪式感。
You know, what kind of killer places the victim's innards around the body? Maybe a Masonic one? Well, maybe. We should be coming to this in our fifth. episode. And once again, of course, the Ripper has struck extremely efficiently and quickly before vanishing into the night. So to quote Philip Sugden, whose book on the Jack the Ripper case is the definitive history. He says, you know, this probably took less than 15 minutes. In that period of time, the killer must have got his victim into Mitre Square,
你知道，什么样的杀手会把受害者的内脏摆在尸体周围？也许是共济会成员？嗯，也许吧。我们应该在第五集里讲到这个。当然，开膛手再次极其高效且迅速地作案，然后消失在夜色中。引用菲利普·萨格登（Philip Sugden）的话，他的那本关于“开膛手杰克”案的书是权威历史。他说，这可能用了不到15分钟。在那段时间里，杀手一定已经把受害者带到了米特广场，
assuming she's not there already, killed her, mutilated her, done all his sort of operations on the body, and then got away, and he has taken with him her womb and her left kidney. And once again, he has done this almost completely unseen and undetected. So we're still in the small hours of Sunday, the 30th of September, and we now have two murder investigations going on simultaneously. So there's the Elizabeth Stride one in Whitechapel and this other one now in the city of London. And they are under different police jurisdictions, because the city of London has its own
假设她还没在那儿，杀了她，损毁了她，对尸体进行了各种“手术”，然后逃之夭夭，他还带走了她的子宫和左肾。再一次，他几乎完全是在无人看见、未被察觉的情况下完成的。所以我们现在还在9月30日星期日的凌晨，我们现在同时有两起谋杀案在调查。一起是白教堂的伊丽莎白·斯泰德案，另一起是现在伦敦市的这起。它们属于不同的警察管辖区，因为伦敦市有自己的
police force. Exactly. So not part of the Metropolitan Police. So let's begin with the one in Whitechapel, the first one, the one we discussed last time, Dutfield's Yard, Elizabeth Stride. So as we heard about her last time, she's Swedish, she's born in Gothenburg, she's come to England, she probably worked as an occasional prostitute. And if you want to find out more about her, club members can do so in our bonus.
警察部队。没错。所以不属于伦敦警察厅。那么让我们从白教堂的那起开始，也就是我们上次讨论的那起，达特菲尔德庭院的伊丽莎白·斯泰德案。正如我们上次听到的，她是瑞典人，出生在哥德堡，来到英国，可能偶尔做妓女。如果您想了解更多关于她的信息，俱乐部成员可以在我们的加更节目中收听。
And if you want to join them, just head to the rest is history.com. So she had been seen in a cheap lodging house and flower and Street just before seven o'clock. We don't know when she went out exactly. We don't know where she was going. We don't know whether she was going out to try to solicit to get money for a bed. All of this is very unclear. We know that at some time that evening she had some bread and cheese and she possibly had some drinks. And she also got hold of some hard sweets kind of breath fresheners called I think they're called cashew or something, aren't they? And she's holding them in her hand. And she's also got hold of a red rose.
如果您想加入他们，只需访问therestishistory.com。她在晚上七点前曾在花与迪恩街的一家廉价寄宿公寓被看到。我们不知道她确切是什么时候出去的。我们不知道她要去哪儿。我们不知道她出去是为了拉客挣钱付房费。所有这些都很不清楚。我们知道那天晚上她吃了一些面包和奶酪，可能还喝了一些酒。她还拿到了一些硬糖，一种口气清新剂，我想它们叫“腰果糖”（cashew）还是什么的，对吧？她正拿在手里。她还拿了一朵红玫瑰，
which she has fixed to her bodice. And then somehow she's ended up in Dutfield's yard outside this sort of socialist club where she has been murdered. Do you know the site of it now? It's a school playground. Oh my God, really? Yeah, I went and investigated all the places
别在胸前。然后不知怎么的，她最终来到了达特菲尔德庭院，在那家社会主义俱乐部外面被谋杀了。你知道现在那里的遗址吗？那是一个学校操场。天哪，真的吗？是的，我去调查了所有发生过案件的地方。对。我的意思是，那可能是最不合适的地方了。那里有牌匾之类的吗？没有。因为显然学校不想引起人们对孩子们玩耍的地方的注意。
where it happened. Right. And I mean, that's probably the least appropriate place. Yeah. And is there a plaque or anything? No. Because obviously the school doesn't want to draw attention to the place where all the little children are playing.
我认为应该立一块牌匾。首先，孩子们会喜欢的。其次，我认为应该标记出她最后的时刻。不管怎样，我会和学校谈谈。所以，显而易见的问题是，她是怎么死的？和其他受害者一样，她的喉咙被割开了，脖子和肩膀上似乎有淤青。检查她尸体的医生有两个。其中一个是给安妮·查普曼做尸检的那个人，乔治·巴克斯特·菲利普斯（Dr. George Baxter Phillips）医生。
I think there should be a plaque. First of all, the kids would love it. And secondly, I think it's, you should mark where she, her last moments, I think. Anyway, I'll take that up with the school. So, obvious question, how did she die? As with the other victims, her throat was cut, and it seems like there were bruises on her neck and shoulders. The doctors who examined her body, there were two different doctors. One of them is the guy who had done the autopsy on Annie Chapman, Dr. George Baxter Phillips.
“巴克斯特”。“巴克斯特”。是的，这肯定是他在学校时的朋友们叫他的名字。他们认为她是被抓住肩膀，然后推倒在地，并在地上被杀害的。现在，哈莉·鲁本霍尔德（Hallie Rubenhold）在她的书《五人》（The Five）中，对受害者的生活进行了精彩的描述，她有一个论点，即受害者都是在睡觉时被杀的，她们无家可归，开膛手只是偶然遇到她们并杀害了她们。我在这里不太确定，因为萨格登指出地面非常泥泞，而且一直在下雨。因此，
The Baxter. The Baxter. Yeah, that's surely what his friends from school. all call him. And they think she had been seized on the shoulders and then pushed to the ground and killed on the ground. Now, Hallie Rubenhold in her book, The Five, which is brilliant on the lives of the victims, has a thesis that the victims were all killed as they slept, that they were homeless, and the Ripper just simply came across them and killed them. I'm not sure about that here, because Sugden points out that the ground was very muddy and it had been raining. And therefore,
似乎不太可能你会躺在泥里睡觉。难道没有警察或医生或某个人说她看起来像是被平放在泥里的吗？被平放，没错，而不是你会选择躺在泥里，肯定不会。我的意思是，关于这件事有太多令人困惑的事情了。为什么她手里还拿着硬糖？为什么没有人听到她尖叫？她离那个俱乐部很近。为什么完全没有挣扎的迹象？
It seems unlikely that you would lie down to sleep in the mud. Wasn't there the policeman or the doctor or somebody said that she seemed to have been laid down in the mud? Being laid down, exactly, rather than you wouldn't like, you wouldn't choose to lie down in the mud, surely. I mean, so many baffling things about it. Why is she still holding the hard sweets in one hand? Why did nobody hear her cry out? She's very close to this club. Why are there no signs of any struggle at all?
最令人困惑的是，为什么伊丽莎白·斯泰德的尸体是唯一没有受到任何损毁的？没有撕裂。你知道，她的尸体，喉咙被割开了，但没有别的。所以有几种理论。一种理论是她实际上是被另一个人杀死的，这是一起无关的谋杀案。所以菲利普斯医生，“巴克斯特”，他认为杀手使用的刀与杀死安妮·查普曼的那把不同，伤口也非常不同。另一方面，许多“开膛手”学者说，作案手法是相似的。
And most bewildering of all, why uniquely is Elizabeth Stride's body not mutilated in any way? There's no ripping. You know, her body, her throat has been cut, but nothing else. So there are a couple of theories. One theory is she's actually killed by a different person, and this is an unrelated murder. So Dr. Phillips, the Baxter, he thought that the killer had used a different knife from the one used to kill Annie Chapman, and that the wound was very different. On the other hand, a lot of Ripper sort of scholars say, you know, the modus operandi is similar.
受害者在东区黑暗角落的地上被杀，喉咙从左到右被割开。所以我认为，概率平衡显示这是一起“开膛手杰克”的罪行。在这种情况下，尸体没有被损毁的解释是，实际上，当那个赶着马车的家伙，我们上次提到的路易斯·迪姆舒茨（Louis Diemschutz），走进庭院时，他实际上打断了开膛手正在进行的邪恶工作。是的。我想这也可能解释了为什么他后来又去犯了第二起谋杀案。没错。
A victim killed while lying on the ground in a dark corner of the east end, the throat cut from left to right. So the balance of probability, I think, is that this was a Jack the Ripper crime. And in that case, the explanation for why the body isn't mutilated is that actually, when that guy and his cart, that we talked about last time, Louis Diemschutz came into the yard, he actually disturbed the ripper in the process of his, you know, his nefarious work. Yeah. And I guess that would then also explain perhaps why he goes on to commit a second murder. Exactly.
是的。你知道，他没有机会做他想做的事，也就是“开膛”。正是如此。我认为这在心理学上完全说得通，对吧？开膛手被剥夺了他真正想要的东西，现在的杀戮已经不足以给他想要的快感了。实际上，正是“开膛”的过程变得越来越极端，越来越恐怖。这就是为什么他觉得有必要再次作案。现在，这第一起罪行，有几个非常有趣的证人。首先，
Yes. You know, he hasn't had the opportunity to do what he wants to do, namely get ripping. Exactly that. I think that makes complete psychological sense, right? The ripper has been cheated of the thing that he really, you know, the killing is now not enough to give him the high that he wants. It is actually the process of ripping which is becoming more and more extreme and more horrific every time. And that's why he feels the need to strike again. Now, this first crime, there are a couple of really intriguing witnesses. So first of all,
有一个叫威廉·史密斯（PC William Smith）的警员。他在谋杀当晚12点30分左右在伯纳街（Burner Street）附近巡逻。他看到一个男人和一个戴着红玫瑰的女人在发现尸体的地方对面街上交谈。他描述那个男人大约28岁，肤色黝黑，留着小黑胡子，穿着黑色剪裁外套，戴着硬毡猎鹿帽，拿着一个报纸包。因为那个被看到与安妮·查普曼交谈的男人也戴着猎鹿帽，不是吗？没错。所以猎鹿帽并不罕见。当然，夏洛克·福尔摩斯就以戴着这种帽子而闻名。
there's a guy called PC William Smith. He was patrolling near Burner Street at about 1230 on the night of the murder. And he saw a man and a woman with a red rose talking across the street from where the body was discovered. And he described the man as about 28 years. So dark complexion, a small dark moustache, wearing a black cutaway coat, wearing a hard felt deer stalker hat, and carrying a parcel in newspaper. Because the man seen talking to Annie Chapman had been wearing a deer stalker hat, hadn't he? Exactly. So deer stalker hats are, you know, they're not uncommon. Of course, Sherlock Holmes is famously portrayed with one.
所以，这可能是另一个人，但帽子在所有证词中不断出现，这很能说明问题。我的意思是，想想看。猎鹿帽，你戴它是为了追踪鹿，当你捕获一只鹿时，你会把它剖开并取出内脏。我只是在想，也许有一个……也许吧。我的意思是，我没想过这一点，汤姆。我不知道。所以还有另一种方式。
So, you know, it could be a different man, but it's telling that the hat keeps reappearing in all the witness statements. I mean, just to think. I mean, a deer stalker, you wear it because you're stalking deer, and when you capture a deer, you rip it open and disembowl it. I just wondering if perhaps there's a... Maybe. I mean, maybe I hadn't thought of that, Tom. I don't know. So there's another way in this.
看看你对这个怎么看。这个人叫以色列·施瓦茨（Israel Schwartz）。他是一名犹太移民，可能来自奥匈帝国的加利西亚。大约12点45分，他走过达特菲尔德庭院时，正如斯旺森（Swanson）总督察在笔记中所述，他看到一个男人停下来与一个站在门口的女人说话。男人试图把女人拉到街上，但他转过身把她扔在人行道上，女人尖叫了三次，但声音不大。在穿过街道对面时，他看到第二个男人站在那里点烟斗。
See what you think of this one. This guy is called Israel Schwartz. Now, he is a Jewish immigrant, and he's probably from Galicia in Austria, Hungary. At about 1245, he is walking past Dutfield's yard when, as Chief Inspector Swanson describes in his notes, He saw a man stop and speak to a woman who was standing in the gateway. The man tried to pull the woman into the street, but he turned around and threw her down on the footway, and the woman screamed three times, but not very loudly. On crossing to the opposite side of the street, he saw a second man standing lighting his pipe.
那个把女人扔在地上的男人，显然对着马路对面的男人喊道：“利普斯基”（Lipski），然后施瓦茨走开了。但发现自己被第二个男人跟踪后，他跑到了铁路拱门处，但那个人没有追那么远。这太诱人了，太神秘了，汤姆。太有趣了。不管怎样，警察把这个叫施瓦茨的家伙带到了停尸房，他说：“这就是那个女人，伊丽莎白·斯泰德就是我看到的那个女人。”他们问：“那两个男人长什么样？”他说基本上那些男人30岁出头，留着胡子，穿着深色外套，第一个男人大约5英尺5英寸高，戴着一种尖顶帽，有点像猎鹿帽。这与第三个
The man who threw the woman down, called out apparently to the man on the opposite side of the road, Lipski, and then Schwartz walked away. But finding that he was followed by the second man, he ran as far as the railway arch, but the man did not follow so far tantalizing it is it's mysterious tom it's intriguing anyway the police take this bloke schwartz to the mortuary and he says this is the woman elizabeth stride is the woman i saw and they say well what do the men look like and he says basically the men were in their early 30s they had mustaches and they wore dark coats and the first man he says was about five foot five and wore a kind of peaked cap a little bit like a deer stalker that tallies with a third
证人吻合，那是一个叫威廉·马歇尔（William Marshall）的劳工。他也说他看到一个女人和一个男人在交谈，男人大约5英尺6英寸，穿着黑色剪裁外套，尖顶帽，穿着得体，说话温和，像个职员。所以这看起来像是所有这些证词中的同一个人，你知道，尖顶帽，5英尺5，5英尺6等等。那第二个男人呢？那个男人怎么回事？所以一些研究开膛手故事的人认为开膛手有同伙。伟大的福尔摩斯。是的，如果这是一个阴谋。
witness, who's a labourer called William Marshall. He also says he saw a woman and a man talking and a man about five foot six and a black cutaway coat, a peaked cap, decently dressed and mild speaking like a clerk. So this is looking like the same man in all of these, you know, peaked cap, five foot five, five foot six, and so on and so forth. What about the second man though? What about this other man? So some people who look into the Ripper story, we think that the rip had an accomplice. Great Scott Holmes. Yes, if this was a conspiracy.
以色列·施瓦茨的描述听起来这两个男人互相认识，其中一个对另一个喊“利普斯基”。但警方报告很清楚，他不能确定这一点。他只是在猜测。还有福尔摩斯？这个“利普斯基”是什么？你怎么看？我很享受播客的这种新氛围，因为我这次被选为福尔摩斯。
Israel Schwartz, his account makes it sound like these two men know each other and the one man shouts to the other man Lipski. But the police report is clear that he can't be sure about that. He's only kind of guessing. And Holmes? What is this Lipski? What do you make of that? You know, I'm enjoying this new vibe to the podcast with being cast as Holmes for once.
太棒了。这是一个非常迷人的谜题，这是“开膛手”故事如何成为1880年代伦敦焦虑之窗的一个很好的例子。“利普斯基”在东区是一个非常响亮的名字，因为在1887年，一个叫以色列·利普斯基（Israel Lipski）的雨伞制造者，
Brilliant. So this is a really fascinating puzzle and this is a really good example of how the Ripper stories a window into the anxieties of 1880s London. Lipski is a really well-known name in the East End because in 1887, a bloke who made umbrellas called Israel Lipski
他最初是另一个波兰犹太人，因谋杀了一名怀孕的年轻女子米里亚姆·安吉尔（Miriam Angel）而被绞死，因为他强迫她喝下硝酸。非常令人不快。这太像“便士恐怖小说”（penny dreadful）了。这在当时是一个非常有争议的案件，因为很多人说利普斯基没有做，这是反犹太主义。利普斯基在被处决前向他的拉比忏悔了。但当时有些人相信他确实做了，要么是因为他被虐待和摧毁了，他只是为了了结此事而忏悔，要么是因为拉比说服他，如果他忏悔，对每个人都更好，对犹太社区也更好。这似乎不可信，
who was originally another Polish Jew had been hanged for murdering a young woman who was pregnant called Miriam Angel because he'd forced her to drink night tric acid. Very unpleasant. That is so penny dreadful. This is a really, really controversial case at the time, because a lot of people said Lipski had not done it, that this was anti-Semitism. Lipsky confessed to his rabbi just before he was executed. But some people believed at the time that he had done so, either because he'd been kind of brutalized and broken and he was just confessing to get it over with, or because the rabbi had persuaded him that it would be better for everybody. if he confessed, and better for the Jewish community. That seems implausible,
他们竟然能把他当作害群之马排斥，而不是看起来好像他们在试图掩盖他们的同教教徒。维多利亚女王对此非常不安，非常担心利普斯基是被陷害的，《帕尔马公报》（Pall Mall Gazette）也是如此，这是一份我们已经听说过一点的报纸，一份我们将会听到更多报道的激进报纸。
that they could then kind of ostracize him as a bad egg, rather than it look as though they were trying to cover up for one of their co-religionists. Queen Victoria was very agitated about this and was very worried that Lipsky had been framed, as was the Palmaal Gazette, a newspaper we've heard a bit about already campaigning newspaper we were hearing more from.
所以无论如何，利普斯基是1887年、1888年白教堂的一个众所周知的嘲讽对象，人们会说，哦，你是个典型的利普斯基，诸如此类。是的，就像你是个哈罗德·希普曼（Harold Shipman）或者其他什么人。你有没有在人们把你比作哈罗德·希普曼的圈子里混过？没有，但你可以，我的意思是，它变成了一个杀手或类似角色的标准名称。是的，就像“开膛手”，对吧？就像“开膛手杰克”。
So anyway, Lipsky is a sort of well-known, sort of taunt in Whitechaple in 1887, 1888, people will say, oh, you're a regular Lipsky and all of this kind of thing. Yeah, so kind of like you're Harold Shipman or your whatever. Did you ever move in circles where people compared you to Harold Shipman? No, but you could, I mean, it becomes a kind of a standard name for a killer or something. Yeah, like The Ripper, right? Like Jack the Ripper.
是的。有几种可能性。一种是这个家伙真的叫利普斯基。这两个男人在合作，利普斯基是开膛手罪行的同谋。我想没人真的相信这一点。菲利普·萨格登提出了一个奇怪的建议，我想，他认为这两个男人在合作，可能，但其中一个人喊“利普斯基”是一个诡计，为了把施瓦茨引开，并嫁祸给当地的犹太人。我不认为这很可能。我的意思是，除非是维多利亚女王的私人外科医生，
Yeah. There are a couple of possibilities. So one is this bloke was genuinely called Lipsky. The two men are working together and Lipsky is a confederate in the Ripper. crimes. I think no one really believes that. Philip Sugden suggests that the two men, this is a bizarre suggestion, I think, from him, that the two men are working together, possibly, but that one of them shouts Lipsky as a trick to throw Schwartz off the scent and incriminate the local Jews. I don't think that's very likely. I mean, unless it's Queen Victoria's personal surgeon
他们急于把水搅浑，但同样，我们会在适当的时候讲到这一点。然后是阿伯林（Abiline）督察，很高兴他回来了，阿伯林督察的论点。他基本上对他的上级说，看，在东区，人们在喊“利普斯基”这个词，作为一种反犹太主义的嘲讽。而施瓦茨有很强的犹太外貌。所以我认为，这是在他停下来看那个男人时对他说的，他显然看到那个男人在虐待死去的女人。所以第二个男人只是一个完全的旁观者，是一个红鲱鱼（干扰项）。第二个男人与任何事情都无关。实际上，基本上，开膛手喊道，你知道，他基本上是在对以色列·施瓦茨喊：“走开，你这个利普斯基。”
and they're desperate to muddy the waters, but again, we will come to this in due course. And then Inspector Abiline, great to have him back, Inspector Abiline's thesis. He basically said to his superiors, look, in the East End, people are shouting the word Lipski as a kind of anti-Semitic taunt. And Schwartz has a strong Jewish appearance. So I am of opinion, it was addressed to him as he stopped to look at the man, he saw apparently ill-using the deceased woman. So that the second man is just a complete bystander in a red herring. The second man has nothing to do with anything. And actually, basically, the Ripper shouted, you know, he's basically shouting, go away, you Lipsky.
这对我来说似乎很有道理。是的。现在，阿伯林的论点有两个含义。这意味着杀手可能来自东区，因为他熟悉东区的俚语，“利普斯基”嘲讽，这是一种东区的东西。其次，这也意味着杀手不是犹太人，
at Israel Schwartz. And that seems to kind of make sense to me, actually. Yeah. Now, there are two implications of Abilin's thesis. That would mean the killer is probably from the East End because he's familiar with the slang of the East End, the Lipsky Taunt, which is a kind of East End thing. Secondly, it also implies the killer is not Jewish
因为如果你自己是犹太人，你不会使用反犹太主义的嘲讽，对吧？除非那是他邪恶狡诈的一部分。确实是，但他必须……不，不，不，我同意。我同意，福尔摩斯。我只是想让你保持警惕。好的，非常好。谢谢。好吧。这就是当晚的第一起罪行。那是伊丽莎白·斯泰德的谋杀案。现在让我们做第二起罪行。所以这是在伦敦市米特广场发现的被极其残忍损毁的尸体。首先，警察发现
because you won't use an anti-Semitic taunt if you're Jewish yourself, right? Unless that's part of his fiendish cunning. It is, but he'd have to... No, no, no, I agree. I agree, Holmes. agree, Holmes. I'm just trying to keep you on your toes. Okay, very good. Thank you. All right. So that's the first crime of the night. That's Elizabeth Stride murder. Let's do the second crime now. So this is the hideously mutilated body found in Mitre Square in the city. Of first, the police found
很难确认她的身份。她显然是一个非常贫穷的女人。她穿着非常旧且脏的衣服。她有几个陶土烟斗和一块手帕。她有两张当铺票，但用的是假名。这对于那些处于下层社会的人来说很常见，最终她的伴侣站了出来，一个叫约翰·凯利（John Kelly）的劳工。他一直和她住在库尼寄宿公寓，那是一个非常破旧的地方。他说：“这是我的伴侣，这基本上是我的女朋友，凯特·康威（Kate Conway）。”实际上，她的名字不是凯特·康威。她是凯瑟琳·埃多斯（Catherine Eddows），她46岁。菲利普·萨顿（Philip Sutton）形容她是所有受害者中最讨人喜欢的，这并不奇怪，
it very hard to identify her. She's clearly a very poor woman. She's wearing very old and dirty clothes. She's got a couple of clay pipes and a handkerchief. And she's got two porn brokers tickets, but they're under false names. That's very common for people who are kind of in the on the underclass, as it were, and eventually her partner comes forward, a labourer called John Kelly. He has been living with her in this Doss house, Cooney's Lodgings House, which is a really run-down place. And he says, this is my partner, this is basically my girlfriend, Kate Conway. Actually, her name is not Kate Conway. She's Catherine Eddows, and she was 46 years old. Philip Sutton describes her as the most likable of all the victims, which is not surprising
因为她来自伍尔弗汉普顿（Wolverhampton）。所以我给你简单勾勒一下凯瑟琳·埃多斯的生活，因为，同样，因为我们想让受害者的故事得以呼吸，我们会在加更节目中讲她。她1842年出生在伍尔弗汉普顿，父母非常年轻，来自锡板加工背景。他们搬到伦敦，英年早逝。她最终成了孤儿。她来回奔波，去过伯明翰、伍尔弗汉普顿、伦敦。她最终和一个叫托马斯·康威（Thomas Conway）的士兵在一起。她和他生活了近20年。他们有三个孩子。经典的模式，她喝酒，他可能很暴力。他们分开了。我想他绝对很暴力，不是吗？因为她总是带着黑眼圈和
time because she's from Wolverhampton. So I'll just give you a very quick sketch of Catherine Edos' life because, again, because we want to sort of let the victim's stories breathe as it were, we'll be doing her in the bonus episode. She's born in Wolverhampton, 1842 to very young parents who came from tin plate working backgrounds. They moved to London and they die young. She ends up as an orphan. She goes sort of back and forth, but she, to Birmingham, Wolverhampton, London. She ends up with a soldier called Thomas Conway. She lives with him for almost 20 years. They have three children. The classic pattern, she drinks, he's probably violent. They separate. I think he definitely is violent, isn't he? Because she's always got kind of black eyes and
之类的。没错。他们陷入了恶性循环。她最终和约翰·凯利在一起。她做零工，但她几乎肯定也参与了偶尔的卖淫。所以这不清楚。她和这个叫凯利的家伙刚在肯特郡采过啤酒花。因为采啤酒花几乎是你如果流落街头所能拥有的最接近假期的东西。没错。成千上万的人会去肯特郡采啤酒花等等。他们走了。他们回来了。她喝醉了。她实际上在周六早些时候因为醉酒被警察抓了。她被关进牢房。警察在周日凌晨一点把她放了出来。她最后的遗言，记录在案的话，是放她出来的警员听到的。她对他说：
things. Exactly. They're into the downward spiral. She ends up with John Kelly. She works as a child woman doing odd jobs, but she's almost certainly involved with casual prostitution as well. So it's unclear. They've just been hot picking in Kent, her and this guy Kelly. Because hot picking is kind of almost the nearest to a holiday that you have if you're kind of on the streets. Exactly. And tens of thousands of people would go hot picking in Kent and so on. They've gone off. They've come back. She's got drunk. She's actually picked up earlier on the Saturday for being drunk by the police. She's put in a cell. The police let her out at one o'clock on the Sunday morning. Her last words, recorded words, which is the constable that lets her out. She says to him,
“好吧，晚安，老伙计。”然后大约40分钟后，她就死了。所以开膛手，你知道，在她被放出来后很快就作案了。现在，正如我已经听到的，她的命运是迄今为止最恐怖的。她的喉咙从左到右被割开了七英寸。她的脸和身体被严重损毁。她的躯干被剖开，内脏被取出放在她的肩膀旁。杀手带走了她的左肾和部分子宫。他还切掉了她一只耳朵的耳垂，不是吗？
all right, good night, old cock. And then about 40 minutes later, she is dead. So the Ripper, you know, struck very quickly after she was let out. Now, as I've already heard, her fate is by far, you know, the most horrific so far. Her throat has been cut for seven inches from left to right. Her face and body have been horribly mutilated. Her torso has been ripped open, her insides removed and put by her shoulder. And the killer has left with her left kidney and part of her uterus. He has also cut off the lobe of one of her ears, hasn't it?
这引起了共鸣，因为在“开膛手杰克”介绍自己的臭名昭著的信中，他说他会切掉下一个受害者的耳朵。所以关于切掉一个耳垂是否算数，存在争论。那是对的。杀手没有做的是切掉她的耳朵，尽管信中说他会这样做。在一般损毁的背景下，切掉耳垂只是一件小事。这看起来不像是一个为了证明之前信中吹嘘而刻意做的事情。不管怎样，检查尸体的外科医生弗雷德里克·戈登·布朗医生确信杀手是在现场瞬间完成的。所以后来当我们谈到疯狂的阴谋论时，认为受害者的尸体是被皇家医生在马车里损毁然后扔在现场的想法，这并不是当时人们检查尸体时的想法。
And this kind of resonates because in the notorious letter where Jack the Ripper introduces himself, he'd said that he would cut off the ears of his next victim. And so this debate as to whether cutting off one lobe counts or not. That is right. What the killer does not do is to cut off her ears, though, which the letter had said that he would. And cutting off the lobe in the context of the general mutilations is only a small thing. It doesn't seem like a deliberate thing that you've done to justify a boast in a letter beforehand. Anyway, the surgeon who looked at the body, Dr. Frederick Gordon Brown, was sure that the killer had done this on the spot within moments. So later on when we get to the mad conspiracy theories, the idea that the victim's bodies were mutilated in a carriage by a royal doctor and then dumped on the spot, this is not what people thought at the time when they inspected the bodies.
戈登·布朗医生还认为杀手一定有一定程度的专业知识。他告诉《每日新闻》，左肾被小心地取出，以至于表明这是由一个不仅知道其解剖位置，而且知道如何取出它的人完成的。现在，再次，
Dr Gordon Brown also thought The killer must have had a degree of expertise He told the daily news The Left Kidney had been carefully taken out in such a manner as to show that it had been done by somebody who not only knew its anatomical position But knew how to remove it Now again
这是否意味着它是医生或外科医生？不，不一定。正如我们所说，它可能是屠夫或屠宰工，或者是医学生，或者是确实研究过解剖学的非常有天赋的业余爱好者，但基本上知道自己在做什么的人，我想。也许是一个习惯于在苏格兰高地追踪鹿的人。
Does this mean that it's a doctor or a surgeon? No, not necessarily It could be, as we've said, a butcher or a slaughterman Or a medical student Or indeed a very talented amateur who studied anatomy, but somebody who basically knows what they're doing, I guess. Someone who's used to stalking deer on the Highlands, perhaps.
也许吧。所以和伊丽莎白·斯泰德的谋杀案一样，有一个有趣的证人证词。有两个朋友，他们都是犹太人，一个叫约瑟夫·拉文德（Joseph Lavender）的商业旅行者，和一个叫约瑟夫·利维（Joseph Levy）的屠夫。他们在凌晨一点半左右离开了一家当地的社交俱乐部。
Maybe. So as with Elizabeth Stride's murder, there is one interesting witness account. There are two friends, they're both Jewish, a guy called Joseph Lavender, a commercial traveller, and Joseph Levy, a butcher. And they were leaving a local social club at half-past warn, or thereabouts.
当他们看到一个男人和一个女人站在附近一条小巷的入口处时，拉文德看得最清楚。嗯，他没看到女人的脸，所以他不能确定那是凯瑟琳·埃多斯。但他说是那个男人大约30岁，大约5英尺4英寸，留着胡子，中等身材，戴着尖顶猎鹿帽。但他认为那个男人看起来很粗鲁、破旧。所以我们对那个男人的长相有稍微不同的描述，但有一些共同特征，不是吗？有的。而且，那是深夜，煤气灯闪烁。
When they saw a man and woman standing at the entrance to a nearby alley, and Lavender saw them most clearly. Well, he didn't see the woman's face, so he couldn't be sure that it was Catherine Eddo's. But he said the man was about 30, about 5'4 7 with a moustache, medium build, and a peaked Deer Stalker's cap. But he thought the man looked rough and shabby. So we've had slightly different accounts of how the man looks, but there are a few common features, aren't there? There are. And also, it's the middle of the night, flickering of the gas lamps.
是的。这一次还有另一个线索，一个非常奇怪且令人不安的线索。在凯瑟琳·埃多斯谋杀案发生后的几分钟内，警察就在米特广场周围的街道迷宫中搜寻。正如我们所描述的，开膛手再次像幽灵一样从他们指缝中溜走了。五分钟路程外，一个叫阿尔弗雷德·朗（Alfred Long）的警员正在巡逻高尔斯顿街（Goulston Street），那是在城市和白教堂之间的边界。在2点55分，他在一个公寓门口发现了一些东西，那是一条沾满血迹的女人围裙。结果发现这是凯瑟琳·埃多斯的围裙。
Yeah. And this time there is another clue, a very strange and disturbing clue. So within minutes of Catherine Edo's murder, the police were scouring this kind of warren of streets around Mitre Square. And as we've described, once again, the killer slipped through their fingers like a ghost. Five minutes away, a guy called Alfred Long, police constable, is patrolling Goulston Street, which is on the sort of boundary between the city and Whitechapel. And at 255, he spotted something in a tenement doorway, and it was a woman's apron wet with blood. And it turns out that this is Catherine Edo's apron.
他环顾四周寻找其他血迹或任何其他线索。然后他看到了别的东西。在门口右侧，黑砖上用白粉笔写着：“犹太人是不会因为任何事情而受到指责的人。”（The Jews are the men that will not be blamed for nothing.）“犹太人”（Jews）这个词拼写为J-U-E-S。是的。所以朗警员把围裙带到了最近的警察局。很快，许多其他警察在这些建筑物周围蜂拥而至。
And he looks around for other signs of blood or any of the other clues. And then he sees something else. To the right of the doorway, written in white chalk on the black bricks are the words, The Jews are the men that will not be blamed for nothing. And the word Jews is spelled J-U-E-S. Yes. So P.C. Long takes the apron to the nearest police station. Soon lots of other policemen are swarming around these buildings.
他们什么也没发现。与此同时，警察局长托马斯·阿诺德（Thomas Arnold）向伦敦警察厅厅长查尔斯·沃伦（Sir Charles Warren）爵士简要介绍了这些涂鸦。局长说：“我想尽快摆脱它。如果我们把它留在墙上，到黎明时分，东区的犹太人就会发生暴乱。”你可以完全理解他为什么这么说。由于1880年代的移民潮，情绪高涨。正如我们在安妮·查普曼谋杀案后看到的那样，有很多人非常热衷于指责东区的犹太人。所以查尔斯·沃伦亲自去了高尔斯顿街，他看着这些文字
They don't find anything. Meanwhile, the police superintendent Thomas Arnold briefs the Met Commissioner, Sir Charles Warren, about this graffiti. And the superintendent says, I want to get rid of this as quickly as possible. If we leave it up on the wall, by dawn, there will be a riot against the Jews of the East End. And you can completely see why he says this. Passions are running high because of the tide of immigration in the 1880s. And as we saw after Annie Chapman's murder, there are a lot of people who are very keen to blame the Jew. of the East End. So Charles Warren goes personally to Galston Street and he looks at the writing
和涂鸦。有些人说：“我们要等摄影师来拍摄涂鸦吗？”他说：“不，天快亮了。我们不能冒让人们看到它的风险。”所以，在5点30分黎明破晓时，粉笔字被擦掉了。所以，你知道，我们没有它的照片。所以，持久的谜团是：谁留下的？这意味着什么？有三种可能性。第一。这完全是巧合。开膛手只是扔掉了围裙，墙上有一些反犹太主义涂鸦。警察自己并不认同。
and the graffiti. Some of the people say, should we wait for a photographer to photograph the graffiti? And he says, no, it's getting light. We cannot risk people seeing it. And so at 5.30 as dawn is breaking, the chalk is wiped away. And so, you know, we have no photo of it. So the enduring mystery, who left it? What does it mean? There are three possibilities. Number one. It's a complete coincidence. The Ripper just threw the apron away and there was some anti-Semitic graffiti on the wall. The police themselves didn't agree with.
有些人说它是新鲜的。有些人说它是褪色的。所以它可能是旧的反犹太主义涂鸦。当然，东区确实有不少反犹太主义涂鸦。然而，菲利普·萨格登指出，这是一栋有很多犹太居民的建筑。他们真的不会把它擦掉吗？我的意思是，如果它是半小时前放上去的人，
Some people said it was fresh. Some people said it was faded. So it could be old anti-Semitic graffiti. Of course, there is a fair bit of anti-Semitic graffiti in the East End. However, Philip Suggton points out, this was a building that had a lot of Jewish residents. Is it really plausible that they wouldn't have wiped it away? I mean, if it had been someone who'd put it up half an hour before,
完全有可能。我想，汤姆，但这确实是一个巧合，不是吗？是的，这是一个巧合，但我假设这种涂鸦一直在出现。在深夜？是的。嗯，我不确定。我必须说，这对我来说是最不可能的解释。解释二，听众可以自己做决定。汤姆，我们不想说教。那是我们在“历史余韵”中最不想做的事。只是提供我自己的结论。嗯，每个人都很感激这一点，每个人都很喜欢。说实话，没人比我更喜欢了。所以下一件事，开膛手留下这条信息是为了嘲讽警察，因为他是犹太人。所以他从杀戮中感到欣快。他处于一种狂喜状态。他向
perfectly plausible. I suppose, Tom, but that really is a coincidence, isn't it? Yeah, it is a coincidence, but I assume that this kind of graffiti is going up all the time. In the middle of the night? Yeah. Well, I'm not sure. That seems to me, I have to say, the like list explanation. Explanation two, listeners can make up their own minds. Tom, we don't want to preach. That's the last thing we do on the rest of the history. Just offering my own conclusions. Well, everyone's grateful for that and everyone enjoys it. No one more than me, to be honest. So the next thing, the Ripper left the message to taunt the police because he was Jewish. So he's euphoric from his killings. He's in a state of ecstasy. He's putting two fingers up to the
世界竖起两根手指，说：“哈哈，犹太人有他们自己的包袱。”第三，开膛手留下了这条信息，但这是一个诡计，为了把警察引开。这就是查尔斯·沃伦爵士的想法。查尔斯·沃伦告诉内政部，他说：“这显然是带着煽动公众反对犹太人的意图写的，这就是为什么我必须摆脱它。”我的意思是，这显然是事实，但这不一定是开膛手写的。我的意思是，没有人会把它放上去而不想要那个结果，我想。
world and saying, ha ha, the Jews have got their own bag. And number three, the Ripper left the message, but it's a trick to put throw the police off the scent. This is what Sir Charles Warren thought. So Charles Warren told the home office, he said it was evidently written with the intention of inflaming the public mind against the Jews, and that's why I had to get rid of it. I mean, that is clearly the case, but it doesn't have to be the Ripper who's written it. I mean, no one would put that up and not want that, I think.
世界，并说，哈哈，犹太人有他们自己的麻烦了。第三，开膛手留下了这条信息，但这只是为了误导警察的诡计。这就是查尔斯·沃伦爵士的想法。所以查尔斯·沃伦告诉内政部，他说这显然是出于煽动公众对犹太人的敌意而写的，这就是我必须把它抹掉的原因。我的意思是，事实显然如此，但这不一定非得是开膛手写的。我的意思是，我想没人会写下那种东西却不希望达到那种效果。
It's a better story if it's the Ripper there, isn't it? Yeah, of course it is. But, you know, I'm applying my razor-sharp powers of deduction and logic here. Well, listen, amaze us now with a razor-sharp powers of deduction and logic, because is there not an exciting conspiracy theory attached to this that you will very much enjoy it? Yes. there's a very notorious, I think, mad, well, I think basically everyone thinks mad book about Jack the Ripper called Jack the Ripper, the Final Solution. And I honestly think that any book
如果开膛手杰克真的在那里，那故事会更精彩，不是吗？是的，当然是。但是，你知道，我在这里运用了我敏锐的推理能力和逻辑。好吧，听着，现在就用你那敏锐的推理能力和逻辑让我们大开眼界吧，因为难道没有一个与此相关的令人兴奋的阴谋论，你会非常喜欢吗？是的。有一本非常臭名昭著的，我认为是疯狂的，好吧，我认为基本上每个人都认为是疯狂的关于开膛手杰克的书，叫《开膛手杰克：终极解决方案》。我真心认为任何书名中带有“终极解决方案”字样的书，最好还是别碰为妙。
with the word final solution in the title is probably best left alone. And it was written by a guy called Stephen Knight. And we will be talking about this in our final episode, but it's a theory about a member of the Royal Family being involved and various masons. And remember that Sir Charles Warren, the head of the Met, is himself a Mason. And he says that the misspelling of Jews, so J-U-W-E-S, is a clue. And it refers to three legendary Masonic figures, Jubella, Jebelo, and Jubalum. And it has to be said that this is, I mean, can I say bollocks on this podcast? I mean, yeah, I guess you can. So these figures had apparently not been part of Masonic ritual in Britain for almost a century, and British Masons never used the term J-U-W-E-S to describe
这本书的作者是一个叫斯蒂芬·奈特的人。我们将在最后一集中讨论这个问题，但这是一个关于皇室成员和各种共济会成员参与其中的理论。请记住，伦敦警察厅厅长查尔斯·沃伦爵士本人就是一名共济会成员。他说“Jews”（犹太人）的拼写错误，即J-U-W-E-S，是一个线索。它指的是三个传奇的共济会人物：朱贝拉、杰贝洛和朱巴勒姆。必须说，这是，我是说，我能在播客里说“胡扯”吗？我是说，是的，我想你可以。所以这些人物显然已经有一个世纪没有出现在英国的共济会仪式中了，而且英国共济会从未使用过“J-U-W-E-S”这个词来描述
them, and there is no link with the Masons at all. Well, we should explore this in greater detail, shouldn't we, in our final episode, where we solve the crime, and we should be digging into the Masonic conspiracy theory, which, spoiler alert, I actually do agree with you, and I think it is completely bonkers. But do remember Sir Charles Warren had Doug had excavated on the site of the temple, and Mason's obsessed with the temple. So who knows, maybe there is something there. That was a tantalizing clue there, Tom.
他们，而且与共济会根本没有任何联系。好吧，我们应该在最后一集中更详细地探讨这个问题，不是吗？届时我们将破获这起案件，我们应该深入挖掘共济会的阴谋论，剧透一下，我其实很同意你的观点，我认为这完全是疯了。但请记住，查尔斯·沃伦爵士曾在圣殿遗址进行过挖掘，而共济会成员对圣殿非常着迷。所以谁知道呢，也许那里真的有什么东西。那真是一个诱人的线索，汤姆。
So let's take a break, and then we'll come back, and we will plunge back into the stricken streets of Whitechapel as the story races towards the next terrible crime. This episode is brought to you by Uber. Now, do you know that feeling when someone shows up for you when you need it most? We all need that sometimes. and Uber knows it.
那么让我们休息一下，然后回来，我们将再次潜入白教堂那些受灾的街道，故事正冲向下一场可怕的犯罪。本集由Uber赞助播出。现在，你知道那种当你最需要的时候有人出现的感觉吗？我们有时都需要那样。而Uber知道这一点。
Uber isn't just a ride or a meal delivered. It's showing up no matter what. Like for your long distance friends, bringing soup when they're sick, sending flowers when they're down. When it really matters, whatever it is, you show up. Where there's a will, we're on our way. Uber, on our way. Download the app today. This episode is brought to you.
Uber不仅仅是乘车或送餐。它是无论发生什么都会出现。就像为了你的远方朋友，在他们生病时送去汤，在他们情绪低落时送去鲜花。当它真正重要时，无论是什么，你都会出现。有志者事竟成，我们在路上。Uber，我们在路上。立即下载应用程序。本集由
by aura frames. History is full of gifts, but the best are those that last. Because photographs have become our modern heirlooms. They're like fragments of the present already turning into history. Orra frames let you relive these memories every day or give them to someone you love. That is our beloved producer Theo pointing at a kebab in Sarajevo. Preload the photos before it leaves the box, add a message, and you can keep updating it from anywhere. Unlimited storage, no subscription, just memories. For a limited time, visitoraframes.co.com.uk and get 35 pounds off, ORA's best-selling Carver matte frame, named the top frame by the independent, and use the promo code history at the checkout.
Aura相框赞助播出。历史充满了礼物，但最好的礼物是那些持久的。因为照片已经成为我们现代的传家宝。它们就像正在变成历史的当下的碎片。Aura相框让你每天都能重温这些记忆，或者把它们送给你爱的人。那就是我们敬爱的制片人西奥在萨拉热窝指着一个烤肉串。在它离开盒子之前预装照片，添加一条信息，你就可以从任何地方不断更新它。无限存储，无需订阅，只有回忆。在有限的时间内，访问auraframes.co.uk并获得35英镑的折扣，购买被《独立报》评为最佳相框的Aura最畅销的Carver哑光相框，并在结账时使用促销代码history。
That's A-U-R-A-U-R-A-C-C-C-O-D-U-K promo code history. This exclusive Black Friday Cyber Monday deal is their best of the year. So order now before it ends. Support the show by mentioning us at checkout. Terms and conditions apply. Hello, I'm Professor Hannah-Fry. And I'm Michael Stevens, creator of V-SOS. We thought we would join you for a moment, completely uninvited.
那是A-U-R-A-F-R-A-M-E-S-点-C-O-点-U-K，促销代码history。这个独家的黑色星期五和网络星期一优惠是他们一年中最好的。所以现在就订购，以免优惠结束。在结账时提到我们以支持本节目。适用条款和条件。你好，我是汉娜·弗莱教授。我是迈克尔·史蒂文斯，V-SOS的创始人。我们想不请自来，加入你们一会儿。
We are not going to stay too long, unless you want us too, of course. We're here to tell you about our brand new show. The rest is science. Every episode is going to start with something that feels initially familiar. And then we're going to unpick it and tear it apart until you no longer recognize it at all. Yeah, banana flavor doesn't taste like bananas. Yeah, what is that about? So it is supposed to taste like an old species of banana that was wiped down in a banana apocalypse.
我们不会待太久，除非你希望我们待久一点，当然。我们来这里是为了告诉你我们的新节目。《其余皆科学》。每一集都将从一些最初感觉熟悉的事情开始。然后我们将拆解它，把它撕碎，直到你完全认不出它为止。是的，香蕉味尝起来不像香蕉。是的，那是怎么回事？所以它应该尝起来像一种古老的香蕉品种，这种香蕉在香蕉末日中被消灭了。
And now you will only find it in botanical collections in the gardens of billionaires. Wow. Banana candy is actually the ghost of a long extinct banana. So if you like scratching the surface, thinking a little bit deeper or weirder. Yes, definitely that too. You can join Michael and I every Tuesday and Thursday wherever you get your podcasts. Hello, welcome back to The Rest is History and we are in Whitechapel in the heart of the East End and it is the morning of Sunday the 30th of September 1888 and news is spreading across the East End and beyond of the double killing overnight of Elizabeth Stride in Whitechapel, Catherine Eddoz in Mitre Square in the city of London and the police have cordoned off the murder sites but already thousands of people are gathering. outside Maita Square and Duckfield's Yard where Elizabeth Stride had been murdered. And there are newspapers are starting to appear, people hawking them.
现在你只能在亿万富翁花园的植物收藏中找到它。哇。香蕉糖实际上是早已灭绝的香蕉的幽灵。所以如果你喜欢刨根问底，思考得更深一点或更奇怪一点。是的，绝对也是那样。你可以每周二和周四加入我和迈克尔，无论你在哪里收听播客。你好，欢迎回到《其余皆历史》，我们现在在白教堂，在东区的中心地带，现在是1888年9月30日星期日的早晨，关于昨晚在白教堂发生的双重谋杀案的消息正在东区及更远的地方传播，伊丽莎白·斯泰德在白教堂被杀，凯瑟琳·埃多斯在伦敦城的米特广场被杀，警方已经封锁了谋杀现场，但已经有成千上万的人聚集在
The news is spreading virally. Yeah. And there's a massive sense of panic, actually, for the next week or so. So the streets are deserted at night. There are reports that lots of poor homeless women have gone west to the city or to the west end because the streets are better lit there. There are reports of people kind of, those people who don't, the women are huddling together for protection in the East End.
米特广场和达克菲尔德院外，伊丽莎白·斯泰德就是在那里被谋杀的。报纸开始出现，人们在兜售它们。消息像病毒一样传播。是的。实际上，在接下来的一周左右，有一种巨大的恐慌感。所以晚上街道空无一人。有报道称，许多贫穷的无家可归的妇女去了西边的城市或西区，因为那里的街道照明更好。有报道称人们，那些不，妇女们在东区挤在一起寻求保护。
Some women are carrying knives. The local shopkeepers complain officially to the government that people are staying away, especially because in mid-October, there's one of London, Victorian London's perennial fogs. Pea super. A pea-super. A regular P-supor descends. And they actually petition the Home Secretary, and they say basically, you know, you've lost control of law and order in East London, clearly.
有些妇女带着刀。当地店主正式向政府投诉，称人们都在远离，特别是因为在10月中旬，伦敦出现了维多利亚时代伦敦常有的雾。豌豆汤雾。一种豌豆汤雾。一场常规的豌豆汤雾降临了。他们实际上向内政大臣请愿，他们基本上说，你知道，你显然已经失去了对伦敦东区法律和秩序的控制。
Respectable people are not going shopping. And we're losing our livelihoods. And in the meantime, there are loads of mad theories about the killer. You know, there are sort of letters to the Times, some old India hands and things, saying, you know, we recognize this. This is a Laskar at work. I mean, that is what it would be in a Sherlock Holmes story, that idea that the kind of opium-crazed foreigners who've landed on a ship. That kind of, it's exactly what you get in a Victorian crime thriller. It's the sort of the empire coming home, right?
体面的人不去购物。我们正在失去生计。与此同时，关于凶手有大量的疯狂理论。你知道，有一些给《泰晤士报》的信，一些老印度通之类的，说，你知道，我们认出这个了。这是一个拉斯卡人在作案。我的意思是，在福尔摩斯的故事里就是这样，那种鸦片成瘾的外国人在船上登陆的想法。那种，这正是你在维多利亚时代的犯罪惊悚片中得到的。这就像是帝国回家了，对吧？
Or Wilkie Collins or something. There's a diamond involved, almost certainly. Yeah. But a lot of people, I know we've got lots of American listeners, and they'll be pleased to hear that a lot of people assume it must be an American. Because they know that Americans get up to extreme behavior, but also there's been rumors that a man in a soft felt American hat was talking to Elizabeth Stride. And there's even suspicion that may have been done by cowboys, isn't there? Well, I mean, here, this is actually, I think, a kind of very interesting angle on the panic because it's not just cowboys, but also Indians are much on the public mind. because the previous year was when Buffalo Bill had come with his Wild West show
或者是威尔基·柯林斯之类的。几乎肯定涉及一颗钻石。是的。但很多人，我知道我们有很多美国听众，他们会很高兴听到很多人认为这一定是个美国人。因为他们知道美国人会做出极端的行为，而且还有传言说一个戴着软毡美国帽的男人在和伊丽莎白·斯泰德交谈。甚至有人怀疑这可能是牛仔干的，不是吗？好吧，我的意思是，在这里，这实际上，我认为，是恐慌的一个非常有趣的角度，因为不仅仅是牛仔，印第安人也深深地印在公众心中。因为前一年是布法罗·比尔带着他的狂野西部表演来到这里
to coincide with Queen Victoria's Golden Jubilee. And it's really notable when you look at the press coverage how regularly comparisons are made with the mutilations and murders in the East End with the supposed mutilations inflicted by Native Americans. So we actually read one, didn't we, a piece from the Evening Standard, but compared the mutilations to those done by a porn. Indian. And W.T. Stead, so the editor of the Palmaul Gazette in the wake of Annie Chapman's murder, he had pointed out that a Londoner is quite as capable of bathing his hands in blood
以配合维多利亚女王的金禧庆典。当你查看媒体报道时，非常值得注意的是，人们多么经常地将东区的残害和谋杀与美洲原住民所实施的所谓残害进行比较。所以我们实际上读过一篇，不是吗，一篇来自《标准晚报》的文章，但将这些残害与波尼族印第安人所做的进行了比较。而W.T.斯特德，也就是《帕尔马尔公报》的编辑，在安妮·查普曼谋杀案发生后，他指出，伦敦人完全有能力把手浸在血中
as any sue whoever scalped a foe. And of course, Sitting Bull had been part of Buffalo Bill's Wild West show. So I just feel it's clearly part of the kind of the climate of the times that journalists are instinctively reaching for those kind of comparisons. Yeah, and I think there's a case that the Ripper story almost immediately becomes absorbed into the kind of popular culture of London in 1888, doesn't it? It becomes sort of confused with lots of other different things. And actually, people immediately rush to make money from it. I mean, people are, you know, selling special editions of the newspapers and there are some tremendously tasteful ballads, aren't there? Would you like to, are you going to sing this ballad or are you like to
就像任何剥过敌人头皮的苏族人一样。当然，坐牛也曾是布法罗·比尔狂野西部表演的一部分。所以我只是觉得这显然是当时气候的一部分，记者们本能地寻求那种比较。是的，我认为有一种情况是，开膛手的故事几乎立即被吸收进1888年伦敦的流行文化中，不是吗？它变得与许多其他不同的事情混淆了。实际上，人们立即争先恐后地从中赚钱。我的意思是，人们，你知道，在卖报纸的特别版，还有一些非常高雅的民谣，不是吗？你想，你要唱这首民谣吗，还是你想
read it? I mean, I think it's interesting because actually, Catherine Eddo's and Thomas Conway had spent much of their time hawking exactly these kind of ballads. So they would go to places say where people were being hanged and compose these kind of songs and sell them. And now songs are being composed about the murder of Kate Eddo's and the other victims. So this is an example. In famous London City in 1888, four beatly cruel murders have been done. Some say it was old Nick himself or else a Russian Jew. Some say it was a cannibal from the Isle of Kickaboo. Some say it must be bashy bazooks, or else it's the Chinese, come over to Whitechapel to commit such crimes as these. There's something slightly Gilbert and Sullivan about music hall about that, isn't there?
读它？我的意思是，我认为这很有趣，因为实际上，凯瑟琳·埃多斯和托马斯·康威曾花大部分时间兜售这些民谣。所以他们会去人们被绞死的地方，创作这些歌曲并出售它们。现在，关于凯特·埃多斯和其他受害者的谋杀案的歌曲正在被创作。这是一个例子。在1888年著名的伦敦城，发生了四起残忍的谋杀案。有人说是老尼克本人，或者是俄罗斯犹太人。有人说是来自基卡布岛的食人族。有人说是巴什·巴祖克人，或者是中国人，来到白教堂犯下这些罪行。这听起来有点吉尔伯特和萨利文音乐厅的感觉，不是吗？
It's certainly not Tennyson. But it's also that the blame is being put on foreigners. Again, there's this idea that no Englishman could possibly do this. Right. And there's that, I mean, you can completely see how that's part of the same world as Sherlock Holmes, because in Sherlock Holmes, it would be bashy bazooks or the Chinese or something. wouldn't it? So anyway, people are cashing in, they're opening the houses to sightseers. So even that socialist club, where Elizabeth Stride's body was found, they're making money out of it by charging tourists. Socialists. Yeah, that's a lesson for you, Theo. Now, that makes it sound as though people didn't care, but they absolutely did care. And the whole business was a spur, particularly to
这肯定不是丁尼生。但这也是因为责任被归咎于外国人。同样，有一种想法是，没有英国人可能做到这一点。对。而且，我的意思是，你可以完全看出这如何成为福尔摩斯世界的一部分，因为在福尔摩斯中，那将是巴什·巴祖克人或中国人之类的，不是吗？所以无论如何，人们正在利用这一点，他们向游客开放房屋。所以即使是那个发现伊丽莎白·斯泰德尸体的社会主义俱乐部，他们也通过向游客收费来赚钱。社会主义者。是的，这对你来说是个教训，西奥。现在，这听起来好像人们不在乎，但他们绝对在乎。整个事件是一个刺激，特别是对
political radicals. So loads of letters in the newspapers saying, you know, this is a reminder that it's a disgrace that the East End is like this. We should clean up the streets. We should do something for the for the poor. We shouldn't have an underclass in the heart of the imperial city. You know, people feel guilty about it. And again, that's part of the kind of imperial dimension to it, isn't it? That people in London, the capital of the world's greatest empire, justify their empire in terms of a kind of civilising mission. The idea that other parts of the world are savage compared, say, to Britain. But what these murders show is that savagery lurks in the streets of the imperial capital as well. And I know we'll talk about this in the next episode when you're going to be talking about Dr. Jekyll and Mr. Hyde and so on. But it's really striking to me reading a lot of the newspaper commentary, how often people would say things like, you know, that there are people walking around in the East End whose eyes have been opened to the horror that has been lurking among us all this time, that there is something deeply buried in us.
政治激进分子。所以报纸上有很多信件说，你知道，这提醒人们，东区变成这样是一种耻辱。我们应该清理街道。我们应该为穷人做点什么。我们不应该在帝国城市的中心有一个底层阶级。你知道，人们对此感到内疚。同样，这也是帝国维度的一部分，不是吗？伦敦，世界最大帝国的首都，人们以一种文明使命来证明他们的帝国是正当的。认为世界其他地方与英国相比是野蛮的。但这些谋杀案表明，野蛮也潜伏在帝国首都的街道上。我知道我们会在下一集中讨论这个问题，届时你将讨论《化身博士》等等。但阅读很多报纸评论让我印象深刻的是，人们经常说这样的话，你知道，东区有很多人睁开了眼睛，看到了这段时间一直潜伏在我们中间的恐怖，有什么东西深深地埋在我们心里
that has now come out, you know, that people didn't just say it's a foreign menace. There's a lot of commentary that says this is something that has almost been bubbling away in the sewers of our souls all this time. I mean, I think it works in two dimensions. There's the imperial dimension, the idea that the savagery that is conventionally identified with primitive peoples in distant climes is a part of the savagery of the imperial capital. But it's also this idea that there is a darkness, a murderousness, a savagery, lurking in the soul, perhaps of even the most outwardly respectable figure, walking the streets say of the West End. And yeah, we will be coming to this in our next episode. That's a huge part of the Ripper Mystique,
现在已经显露出来了，你知道，人们不仅仅说这是一种外国威胁。有很多评论说，这几乎一直是在我们灵魂的下水道中冒泡的东西。我的意思是，我认为它在两个维度上起作用。一个是帝国维度，即通常与遥远气候下的原始民族联系在一起的野蛮，是帝国首都野蛮的一部分。但这也是一种想法，即有一种黑暗、凶残、野蛮，潜伏在灵魂中，甚至可能是最外表体面的人物，走在西区的街道上。是的，我们将在下一集中讨论这个问题。这是开膛手神秘感的重要组成部分，
isn't it, as it were? So to go back to the investigation, there are lots of calls in the press for a publicly funded bounty or reward. Now, as we described last time, the Home Office hate the thought it rewards because they say a reward is basically invitation to hoaxes. And there's a big disagreement between the Home Secretary, Henry Matthews, and the Commissioner of the Met, Sir Charles Warren, about this. Their relations are terrible already, pretty much, and they're bickering furiously. Basically, by early November, for unrelated reasons, but this is definitely a factor. It's compounded, isn't it? Yeah, it's compounded. Sir Charles Warren has decided to resign, so the head of the Met is going to step down. Now, meanwhile, the incoming head of
不是吗？所以回到调查，媒体有很多呼吁公共资助的赏金或奖励。现在，正如我们上次描述的那样，内政部讨厌奖励的想法，因为他们说奖励基本上是邀请骗局。内政大臣亨利·马修斯和伦敦警察厅厅长查尔斯·沃伦爵士之间对此有很大的分歧。他们的关系已经很糟糕了，他们吵得不可开交。基本上，到11月初，由于不相关的原因，但这绝对是一个因素。它加剧了，不是吗？是的，它加剧了。查尔斯·沃伦爵士决定辞职，所以伦敦警察厅的负责人要下台了。现在，与此同时，即将上任的
The guy's going to be running CID, Criminal Investigation Department, Dr. Robert Anderson, has been away on holiday. Oh, in Switzerland. And the newspapers notice this, and they start to get very outraged. So the Palmael Gazette says that Dr. Anderson, the chief official responsible for the detection of the murderer, is as invisible to Londoners as the murderer himself. Dr. Anderson is taking a pleasant holiday in Switzerland. I mean, newspapers don't change, right? And Dr. Anderson then returns with an absolutely mad idea. He says, we should arrest every prostitute in London, or tell them that the police will not protect them.
将负责刑事调查部（CID）的人，罗伯特·安德森博士，一直在度假。哦，在瑞士。报纸注意到了这一点，他们开始变得非常愤怒。所以《帕尔马尔公报》说，负责侦破凶手的首席官员安德森博士，对伦敦人来说就像凶手本人一样隐形。安德森博士正在瑞士享受愉快的假期。我的意思是，报纸不会改变，对吧？然后安德森博士带着一个绝对疯狂的想法回来了。他说，我们应该逮捕伦敦的每一个妓女，或者告诉她们警方不会保护她们。
And everyone says, ah, this is mad. First of all, the police's own estimates, and don't forget, the definition of prostitution is incredibly vague. They reckon at least 1,200 women would fall under this category and would end up being arrested. They had gone nowhere to put them. And secondly, people point out to Anders, and they say, you know, these women are solicitous. in order to pay for their lodging. They have literally nowhere to go. If we stop them plying their trade,
每个人都说，啊，这太疯狂了。首先，警方自己的估计，别忘了，卖淫的定义非常模糊。他们估计至少有1200名妇女属于这一类，并将最终被捕。他们无处安置她们。其次，人们向安德森指出，他们说，你知道，这些妇女是为了支付住宿费而拉客。她们真的无处可去。如果我们阻止她们从事她们的行业，
they will just be lying in the streets. What are we going to do? So they ditch that idea. They do launch a house-to-house search. And actually, this is interesting because you might assume that everybody in the East End hates the police. Well, I think they do, don't they?
她们就只能躺在街上了。我们该怎么办？所以他们放弃了这个想法。他们确实发起了挨家挨户的搜查。实际上，这很有趣，因为你可能会认为东区的每个人都讨厌警察。好吧，我想他们是这样，不是吗？
In Spittalfields, there's all of this stuff that you can only go in as a policeman in pairs. But obviously times change and now the police are your allies in hunting out the killer. So to do this search, right, this house-to-house search, the police have to ask the permission of every single householder. And almost everybody grants permission. There's virtually no resistance at all. The press are really surprised by this and struck by it that the East End welcomes the police, says, come on, yes, do the search. So they do the search, they don't find anything.
在斯皮塔菲尔德，有所有这些东西，你只能成对地作为警察进入。但显然时代变了，现在警察是你追捕凶手的盟友。所以为了进行这次搜查，对吧，这次挨家挨户的搜查，警察必须征得每一位户主的许可。几乎每个人都给予了许可。几乎没有任何阻力。媒体对此感到非常惊讶，并深受触动，东区欢迎警察，说，来吧，是的，进行搜查。所以他们进行了搜查，他们什么也没发现。
There's also another Sherlock Holmes parallel, actually, an experiment with bloodhounds. Which does not work out well, does it? No. So in the sign of the four, where it's a very good example of the crimes in that Sherlock Holmes home story have been committed by, you know, it's the violence of the empire coming back home, there's a bloodhound called Toby, who's the most brilliant bloodhound in London, and Holmes and Watson follow him across town in search of whatever the guy is called. Jonathan Small is it?
还有一个福尔摩斯的平行案例，实际上，是一个关于猎犬的实验。这并没有产生好的结果，不是吗？不。所以，在《四签名》中，这是一个很好的例子，福尔摩斯故事中的犯罪是由，你知道，是帝国暴力回归家园，有一只叫托比的猎犬，它是伦敦最聪明的猎犬，福尔摩斯和华生在城里跟着它寻找那个叫什么的人。是乔纳森·斯莫吗？
who's the killer or something involved with the killer, I can't remember. Anyway, the press have been pestering the home office, you know, use bloodhounds. And eventually they get two dogs called Barnaby and Bergo. And they do experiments in Regent's Park and Hyde Park. But comically, this doesn't happen in Sherlock Holmes. There's a massive disagreement in falling out about who's going to pay for the dog's insurance. So eventually the dog breeder loses patience with the police and he takes them to a dog show instead. And so the police lose the cooperation of Barnaby and Bergo.
他是凶手还是与凶手有关的人，我不记得了。无论如何，媒体一直在纠缠内政部，你知道，使用猎犬。最终他们得到了两只叫巴纳比和伯戈的狗。他们在摄政公园和海德公园进行了实验。但滑稽的是，这并没有发生在福尔摩斯中。关于谁来支付狗的保险费，发生了巨大的分歧和争吵。最终，狗饲养员对警察失去了耐心，他带它们去参加狗展了。所以警察失去了巴纳比和伯戈的合作。
But as Charles Warren said, this is a mad experiment. Because we don't have any, we don't have the killer's blood or any of his clothes or anything like that. So what are they supposed to be tracing? Yeah. I mean, Warren's got his finger on the pulse there. Well, I've got an even better wheeze for you. So there were no police women in the Met. So they can't entrap the Ripper.
但正如查尔斯·沃伦所说，这是一个疯狂的实验。因为我们没有任何，我们没有凶手的血或他的任何衣服之类的东西。所以他们应该追踪什么？是的。我的意思是，沃伦在这里抓住了重点。好吧，我有一个更好的主意给你。所以伦敦警察厅没有女警察。所以她们不能诱捕开膛手。
They can't send police women out to kind of. lure him. Do they, however, have any young lads who could plausibly pass? Well, so the press have been pestering the Met and saying, could you not, you know, send out people dressed as women to lure him? And the Met point out, they say all our recruits by law have to be more than five or seven. So an age when people are slightly shorter than they are today, they will stand that, it will be very conspicuously not women. But one bloke did try this. He was Detective Sergeant Robinson of G Division and he went and sort of, he dressed up and he stood around. He was accosted by some cab washers, so people washing down, you know, hackney carriages. Was this because they felt
她们不能派女警察出去，你知道，引诱他。然而，她们有任何看起来像女人的年轻小伙子吗？好吧，媒体一直在纠缠伦敦警察厅，说，你们能不能，你知道，派人打扮成女人来引诱他？伦敦警察厅指出，他们说我们所有的招募人员按法律规定必须超过五英尺七英寸。所以在一个人们比今天稍微矮一点的时代，她们会站着，这会非常显眼地不是女人。但有一个家伙确实尝试过。他是G部门的侦探警长罗宾逊，他去，他打扮了一下，站在那里。他被一些洗车工搭讪了，就是那些洗出租马车的人。这是因为他们觉得
that he wasn't really plausible? I don't know. They basically saw this Blake. One of them shouted at him. Now, this is some form of slang that I don't really understand, but they shouted at him, you're cats and dogs, aren't you? And then they stabbed him in the face. Oh, my God. So it was quite a big altercation. He had to be rescued by other policemen. So that's a lesson to you, Tom. If you go on one of your walks in the East End, be careful how you dress, because I don't want, I don't want you to be accused of being cats and dogs and stabbed in the face. Anyway, the various police wheezes don't really work. I'm not surprising, you start to get genuine vigilantes. So last time we mentioned the Mile End Vigilance Committee, which was dominated by local Jewish
他不太像吗？我不知道。他们基本上看到了这个家伙。其中一个人对他大喊。现在，这是一种我不太理解的俚语，但他们对他喊道，你是猫和狗，不是吗？然后他们刺伤了他的脸。哦，我的上帝。所以这是一场相当大的争吵。他不得不被其他警察救走。所以这对你来说是个教训，汤姆。如果你去东区散步，注意你的穿着，因为我不希望，我不希望你被指控为猫和狗而被刺伤脸部。无论如何，各种警察的诡计并没有真正奏效。我不奇怪，你开始得到真正的治安维持者。所以上次我们提到了迈尔恩德警惕委员会，它由当地犹太人主导
tradesmen, and they would meet at the Crown Pub on Myeland Road, and they would organize patrol. They would get unemployed locals to do patrols. And they would give them a little bit of money and they'd give them a whistle, a stout stick and some goloshes. I don't know why particularly they'd give them these galoshes. But basically, this doesn't act. You know, there are two different schools of thoughts on this. Number one is the police didn't really like these vigilante patrols for obvious reasons. And it also made their job more difficult because now there are lots of strange men kind of lurking around the streets with galoshes and upsetting the locals and stuff. But there is an argument, there is now a delay of six weeks before the Ripper strikes again. And this may be
商人，他们会在迈尔恩德路的皇冠酒吧见面，他们会组织巡逻。他们会找失业的当地人进行巡逻。他们会给他们一点钱，给他们一个哨子、一根粗棍子和一些套鞋。我不知道为什么他们特别给他们这些套鞋。但基本上，这并没有起作用。你知道，关于这一点有两种不同的思想流派。第一是警察因为显而易见的原因并不真正喜欢这些治安巡逻。这也使他们的工作更加困难，因为现在有很多奇怪的男人在街上徘徊，穿着套鞋，让当地人不安等等。但有一个论点，现在开膛手再次袭击之前有六周的延迟。这可能是
because the patrols are a bit of a deterrent. There are a lot more people out on the streets, like with stout sticks and goloshes. And this may explain while the next crime happens indoors rather than outside because of all these patrols. So meanwhile, the press are getting more and more critical of the police. So they call them rotten, they say they're incompetent. even the conservative papers. So the Daily Telegraph we mentioned a few times. It slams what it calls
因为巡逻队是一种威慑。街上有更多的人，拿着粗棍子和套鞋。这可能解释了为什么下一次犯罪发生在室内而不是室外，因为所有这些巡逻队。所以与此同时，媒体对警察的批评越来越多。所以他们称他们为腐烂，他们说他们无能。即使是保守派报纸。《每日电讯报》我们提到过几次。它抨击了它所谓的
the notorious and shameful shortcomings of the detective department or rather of the botched up makeshift which does duty for a detective department, Scotland Yard. They call the Tory Home Secretary, Mr Matthews,
侦探部门臭名昭著和可耻的缺点，或者更确切地说是为侦探部门、苏格兰场服务的拙劣的临时措施。他们称托利党内政大臣马修斯先生，
they call him a helpless, heedless, useless figure. Which I think is actually a little bit harsh. The police are doing all they can. They're trying lots of different things, but this is a really, really hard crime to solve. And now we come back to this issue.
他们称他为一个无助、粗心、无用的数字。我认为这实际上有点严厉。警察正在尽他们所能。他们正在尝试许多不同的事情，但这确实是一个非常非常难破的案件。现在我们回到这个问题。
of the Ripper taunting the police. We already mentioned the Dear Boss letter. You know, the letter in which he had said he would cut a victim's, if this is the Ripper, which we actually don't think it is, that he would cut the victim's ears off and then, of course, he doesn't do it. But then on Monday the 1st of October, the Central News Agency got a second message. And this was a blood-stained postcard with a London East postmark dated the first of October. October. So it could have been posted after the Catherine Edo's murder made the newspapers. In other words, the person, it could be a hoaxer who's read about the murder. And most handwriting experts
关于开膛手嘲弄警察。我们已经提到了“亲爱的老板”信。你知道，他在信中说他会切掉受害者的，如果这是开膛手，我们其实认为不是，他会切掉受害者的耳朵，然后，当然，他没有这样做。但随后在10月1日星期一，中央新闻社收到了第二条信息。这是一张带有伦敦东区邮戳的血迹斑斑的明信片，日期是10月1日。10月。所以它可能是在凯瑟琳·埃多斯的谋杀案登上报纸后寄出的。换句话说，这个人，它可能是一个读过谋杀案的骗子。大多数笔迹专家
think it's written by the same person who had written the previous Dear Boss letter. Tom, you want to give us the, in your excellent Australian accent, the text of this postcard. I wasn't codding dear old boss when I gave you the tip. You'll hear about saucy Jack's work tomorrow. double event this time, number one, squirled a bit, couldn't finish straight off. It's not time to get ears off for police. Thanks for keeping last letter back till I got to work again. Jack the Ripper. So coppers of this were published on posters outside every police station, and then they were
认为它是写前一封“亲爱的老板”信的同一个人写的。汤姆，你想用你出色的澳大利亚口音给我们读一下这张明信片的文字吗？我给你提示时并没有在骗你，亲爱的老板。你明天会听到俏皮杰克的工作。这次是双重事件，第一，有点搞砸了，没能直接完成。没时间给警察割耳朵了。谢谢你把上一封信留着直到我再次工作。开膛手杰克。所以这些警察的副本被张贴在每个警察局外的海报上，然后它们被
published in the newspapers on the 4th of October, because the police were desperate to basically, you know, say, do you know this, ma'am? The general consensus, I think, is that these are not real. Neither this or the dear boss. to repeat, there are no spelling mistakes at all, although the punctuation is very all over the shop. There are capital letters as this should be. There are full stops however as there should be.
在10月4日的报纸上发表，因为警察绝望地基本上，你知道，说，你知道这个人吗？我认为普遍的共识是，这些不是真的。无论是这个还是“亲爱的老板”。重复一遍，没有任何拼写错误，尽管标点符号非常混乱。有大写字母，正如应该的那样。有句号，正如应该的那样。
And it feels a little bit like somebody is trying to pretend to be less educated than he is. It's also somebody you can come up with the brilliant name of Jack the Ripper. Yeah, the Ripper, exactly. Almost certainly, I think, a young reporter or somebody like that who's covering the case. And the result of the police publicising this is a flood. of hoax letters. They are deluged with false leads and it reminds me very much of what happened in the 1970s with the Yorkshire Ripper case when there was the police publicised the work of another hoaxe who was called Weirside Jack. And then they were absolutely deluged with false
感觉有点像有人试图假装比他受教育程度低。这也是一个能想出“开膛手杰克”这个绝妙名字的人。是的，开膛手，完全正确。我几乎可以肯定，是一个年轻的记者或类似的人在报道这个案件。警察公开这一点的结果是洪水般的骗局信件。他们被虚假线索淹没，这让我想起1970年代约克郡开膛手案发生时的情况，当时警察公开了另一个叫“堰边杰克”的骗子的工作。然后他们被绝对淹没了虚假
information and it made almost impossible for them to sift through it all. So that's the postcard. And then just over two weeks later comes the most infamous letter of all. So this was addressed to the new chairman of the Mile End Vigilance Committee, the kind of vigilante group, Mr. George Lusk. And it arrived at his house in Mile End on the evening of Tuesday, the 16th of October. So he gets a small parcel wrapped in brown paper with a letter. And he opens the box and it contains what is clearly half a kidney,
信息，这使得他们几乎不可能筛选所有信息。所以这就是明信片。然后两周多一点后，最臭名昭著的信件出现了。所以这是写给迈尔恩德警惕委员会新主席，那种治安维持组织，乔治·拉斯克先生的。它在10月16日星期二晚上到达他在迈尔恩德的家。所以他收到一个小包裹，用棕色纸包着，里面有一封信。他打开盒子，里面装着显然是半个肾脏，
a human kidney. And the letter, do you want to give us the letter? Yeah, it has the most chilling opening, doesn't it? Which has often been rehearsed from hair. And it's Mr. Luss. I send you half the kidney. I took from one woman preserved it for you till the piece. I fried and ate it.
一个人类肾脏。还有那封信，你想读一下那封信吗？是的，它有一个最令人不寒而栗的开头，不是吗？这经常被排练过。它是拉斯克先生。我寄给你半个肾脏。我从一个女人身上取下的，为你保存到那块。我煎了吃了。
It was very nice. I may send you the bloody knife that took it out. If you only wait a while longer, signed. Catch me when you can, Mr. Lusk. The bit of the beginning from hell, very famous because that inspires the enormous graphic novel by Alan Moore, which we might talk about in our final episode. For those people who you can't tell from Tom's reading,
味道很好。我可能会寄给你那把取下它的血淋淋的刀。如果你再等一会儿，签名。能抓到我就抓到我，拉斯克先生。开头那句“来自地狱”，非常有名，因为它启发了艾伦·摩尔那部巨大的图画小说，我们可能会在最后一集中谈论它。对于那些你从汤姆的阅读中看不出来的人，
a lot of that is misspelled, isn't it? So preserved or sore. Yeah, kind of faintly Irish, perhaps. Yes, exactly, which we will come to. Lusk took the kidney to a pathologist to examine it in the microscope and said he thought it was human. There are some claims,
其中很多拼写错误，不是吗？所以保存或酸。是的，有点淡淡的爱尔兰味，也许。是的，完全正确，我们稍后会谈到。拉斯克把肾脏带给病理学家在显微镜下检查，他说他认为那是人类的。有一些说法，
you see them often repeated in Ripper books, that he identified it as the kidney of a 45-year-old woman who was a heavy drinker. But actually, the pathologist said that was completely invented and made up by the newspapers. The city police surgeon agreed,
你经常在开膛手书中看到它们被重复，他将其鉴定为一个酗酒的45岁女性的肾脏。但实际上，病理学家说那是报纸完全编造和捏造的。城市警察外科医生同意，
It was a human kidney, but there's no evidence that it came from Catherine Eddo's. It could have come from any recent autopsy, and it could have been sent in by medical students, for example. The handwriting analysis of this letter is that this is not somebody disguising their writing. There are lots of mistakes, and it is very clearly written quickly and smoothly, not by somebody painstakingly trying to disguise their hand. But it's clearly not the same person as the dear boss person. And also the postcard. So those two Jack the Ripper messages.
这是一个人类肾脏，但没有证据表明它来自凯瑟琳·埃多斯。它可能来自任何最近的尸检，并且可能是由医学生寄出的，例如。这封信的笔迹分析是，这不是有人在伪装他们的笔迹。有很多错误，而且它非常清楚地写得很快很流畅，不是由那种费尽心思试图伪装笔迹的人写的。但这显然不是“亲爱的老板”那个人。还有明信片。所以那两条开膛手杰克的信息。
And Tom, as you said, the spelling looks like it could be Irish. So preserved, for example, which is a more kind of Irish formula apparently. Sor. Sore. Exactly. Writing S-O-R. So there are people who think there is a link to, as we will come to in the final episode, an Irish-American suspect, Dr. Tumblety, who is a very,
汤姆，正如你所说，拼写看起来可能是爱尔兰语。例如，保存，这显然是一种更爱尔兰式的公式。酸。酸。完全正确。写S-O-R。所以有些人认为这与，正如我们将在最后一集中谈到的，一个爱尔兰裔美国嫌疑人，坦布尔蒂博士有关，他是一个非常，
very, very peculiar person indeed. It's harder to dismiss this, I think, than the other letters. We don't know who the kidney is. You know, could this be a letter from the Ripper? We just don't know. Now, the police, as we've said, are deluged with, I mean, these are not the only hoax letters they get. They're the most famous ones, but there are others. If you read the memoirs of the policeman or interviews with them, they basically say, we were totally overwhelmed. So Chief Inspector Donald Swanson, who was leading the investigation at Scotland Yard, he said that on just the Elizabeth Stride murder alone, his men detained 80 different people, they followed up leads on more than 300 other people, and they had 994 different files open at once. Inspector Abiline, who's in charge of the investigation in Whitechapel, remembered later that his team had 1,600 different files, and he himself was patrolling the streets to set an example to his men, in Nelsonian till 4 o'clock in the morning, then he'd often come home and then he'd immediately
非常，非常奇怪的人。我认为这比其他信件更难驳回。我们不知道肾脏是谁的。你知道，这可能是开膛手的一封信吗？我们只是不知道。现在，警察，正如我们所说，被淹没了，我的意思是，这些不是他们收到的唯一骗局信件。它们是最有名的，但还有其他的。如果你读警察的回忆录或对他们的采访，他们基本上说，我们完全被压垮了。所以领导苏格兰场调查的首席督察唐纳德·斯旺森说，仅在伊丽莎白·斯泰德谋杀案上，他的手下就拘留了80个不同的人，他们跟进了300多人的线索，他们同时打开了994个不同的档案。负责白教堂调查的阿伯林督察后来回忆说，他的团队有1600个不同的档案，他自己也在街上巡逻，为他的手下树立榜样，像纳尔逊一样直到凌晨4点，然后他经常回家，然后他会立即
get a telegram saying, come back to Whitechap, we've got a new suspect. So they are exhausted and they are getting nowhere near finding the killer. And what all these letters suggest is that Jack the Ripper is already becoming a literary figure. Yes. There are people who are writing words for him or writing, composing actions for him that are filling in the gaps. And this, of course, is something that will be repeated decade after decade after decades. So we come towards the end of October. The police have really got no clues at all. Robert Anderson writes a report saying that CID has not got the slightest clue of any kind. And on 24th of October, Sir Charles Warren reports to the Home Office, he says,
收到电报说，回到白教堂，我们有一个新嫌疑人。所以他们精疲力竭，离找到凶手还差得远。所有这些信件都表明，开膛手杰克已经成为一个文学人物。是的。有人在为他写词，或者在写，为他创作动作，填补空白。当然，这是几十年又几十年又几十年都会重复的事情。所以我们接近10月底。警察真的没有任何线索。罗伯特·安德森写了一份报告，说刑事调查部没有任何线索。10月24日，查尔斯·沃伦爵士向内政部报告，他说，
despite numerous and searching inquiries, they've produced no tangible result. The vigilante patrols are starting to dry up now because the weeks have passed and the Ripper has not killed again. The Mile End Vigilance Committee runs out of money and has to appeal for public subscriptions. One of the constables on the case, like Walter Dew, notes in his memoirs many years later, he says at this point, the prostitutes of the East End, who had previously sort of vanished from the streets, start to come back. And when he passes them, they will sometimes shout out to him, jovially, I'm the next for Jack. You know, they're making light of it now. Yeah, making a joke to cheer themselves up.
尽管进行了无数次搜查，但没有产生任何有形的结果。治安巡逻队现在开始枯竭，因为几周过去了，开膛手没有再次杀人。迈尔恩德警惕委员会没钱了，不得不呼吁公众认购。案件中的一名警员，像沃尔特·杜，多年后在他的回忆录中写道，他说在这一点上，之前从街上消失的东区妓女开始回来了。当他经过她们时，她们有时会愉快地对他大喊，我是下一个杰克。你知道，她们现在在开玩笑。是的，开个玩笑让自己振作起来。
Now, one of the women he sees calls herself Mary Jane Kelly. We know that she used to read about the killings, because she used to ask her partner, who's a guy called Joe Barnett, who lives with her in a little kind of court called Miller's Court off Dorset Street, and he would read her stories about them. But it didn't deter her from going out on the streets, because PC Dew, as he then was, says. Often I had seen her parading along Commercial Street between Flower and Dean Street and Allgate or along Whitechapel Road. she was usually in the company of two or three of her kind fairly neatly dressed and invariably wearing a clean white apron but no hat no hat not respectable so we come to the morning of the
现在，他看到的其中一个女人自称玛丽·简·凯利。我们知道她过去常读关于杀戮的事情，因为她过去常问她的伴侣，一个叫乔·巴内特的家伙，他住在多塞特街外一个叫米勒法院的小院子里，他会给她读关于它们的故事。但这并没有阻止她走上街头，因为当时还是警员的杜说。我经常看到她在商业街、花与迪恩街和奥尔盖特之间或沿着白教堂路游荡。她通常和两三个同类在一起，穿着相当整洁，总是穿着干净的白围裙，但没有帽子，没有帽子，不体面，所以我们来到
ninth of November it's the day of the lord mayor's show and like a lot of people mary jane kelly has been looking forward to it now that morning her landlord who is a shopkeeper called john mccarthy has been checking his books he notices that she is 29 shillings behind with the rent and he sends his young assistant, Thomas Beaulia, to see if she has some of the money. And at 1045, Beaulia goes and he knocks on the door of 13 Miller's court and there's no answer. And he knocks again and there's still no answer. He goes round the corner where there's a broken window and he pulls aside the curtain. And when he pulls aside the curtain, he reels backwards in absolute shock.
11月9日，那是市长秀的日子，像很多人一样，玛丽·简·凯利一直很期待。那天早上，她的房东，一个叫约翰·麦卡锡的店主一直在查账，他注意到她拖欠了29先令的房租，他派他的年轻助手托马斯·博利亚去看看她是否有钱。在10点45分，博利亚去了，他敲了米勒法院13号的门，没有人回答。他又敲了一次，还是没有人回答。他绕到拐角处，那里有一扇破窗户，他拉开了窗帘。当他拉开窗帘时，他因绝对的震惊而向后踉跄。
and horror. He goes and gets his boss. They end up going to the police station and they fetch two officers, Inspector Walter Beck, and this guy, Walter Dew, I've already mentioned. And Beck, the inspector, peers through the window first and then he staggers back. We're told his face as white as a sheet. And he says, for God's sake, Jude, don't look. But Jew cannot stop himself. He puts his face to the window and then he says, when my eyes, had become accustomed to the dim light. I saw a sight which I shall never forget
和恐惧。他去叫他的老板。他们最终去了警察局，找来了两名警官，沃尔特·贝克督察和我已经提到的沃尔特·杜。贝克，督察，先透过窗户窥视，然后他向后踉跄。我们被告知他的脸像纸一样白。他说，看在上帝的份上，杜，别看。但杜无法阻止自己。他把脸贴在窗户上，然后他说，当我的眼睛习惯了昏暗的光线。我看到了一个我永远不会忘记的景象
to my dying day. So next time we will reveal what he saw through the window of 13 Miller's Court. We will tell the story of Mary Jane Kelly and her terrible fate. And we'll also be looking
直到我死的那一天。所以下次我们将揭示他在米勒法院13号的窗户里看到了什么。我们将讲述玛丽·简·凯利和她可怕命运的故事。我们还将看看
at the cultural hinterland of the Ripper murders. We'll be looking at Dr. Jackal and Mr. Hyde. We'll be looking at Sherlock Holmes and we will be asking how it was that Jack the Ripper came to be enshrined as history's first serial killer. And then our final episode, our fifth episode in the series, we will be examining the various suspects and, for the first time ever, unveiling the definitive killer. And if you're not a member of The Rested History Club and you would like to hear them, then you can sign up at the Restless History.com. But for now, goodbye.
在开膛手杰克谋杀案的文化腹地。我们将探讨《化身博士》，我们将审视夏洛克·福尔摩斯，并探讨开膛手杰克是如何被奉为史上第一位连环杀手的。在我们的最后一集，也就是本系列的第五集，我们将审视各种嫌疑人，并首次揭开最终凶手的真面目。如果您还不是“休息历史俱乐部”的成员，并且想收听这些内容，可以在Restless History.com注册。但现在，再见。
Bye-bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。